[Music]
don't you wish there was a place you
could go to meet fun
sexy singles who also agree the
holocaust was a hoax
now there's a dating site for people who
look and think like you
it's aryanmingle.com the hottest hookup
for the master race
donald trump said it himself there are
lots of good guys on our side
and you can swipe alt right on all of
them
meet goebbels 143. he's a scorpio
an animal lover and supports forced
sterilization to maintain a white
majority
or there's mind guy 82 he loves spooning
quoting angerman and can prove that jews
control the global markets
just look at all of these genetically
superior gentlemen
signing up is easy just choose a
username profile picture
the amount of time you've been
unemployed where you live and the number
of times you've had sex
i'm amazed at their selection i mean
there's way more women than i've met at
our rallies
oh yeah so i heard about this new dating
site so i signed up
what's it called again aaron mingle
not again i need a new
computermingle.com
[Music]
[Applause]
you